y
[Música]
en perú el presidente del congreso
manuel merino es acusado de intento de
complot después de que contactar a altos
mandos militares para respaldar el
juicio político que podría llevar a la
destitución del actual presidente martín
vizcarra merino asumiría el poder en
caso de que vizcarra sea destituido
las víctimas fatales por los incendios
que golpean la costa oeste de eeuu desde
mediados de agosto aumento alrededor de
30 de los bomberos de los estados de
washington oregón y california siguen
luchando contra las llamas y se
organizan campamentos para los más de
500.000 evacuados
la crisis humanitaria en la isla griega
de lesbos tras el incendio en el
campamento de moria donde viven casi
13.000 refugiados siguen generando
preocupación a nivel internacional hoy
unas 200 personas ingresaron al nuevo
campamento destinado para 3000 de ellas
después de que un incendio arrasara con
moria y dejará aún peor en peores
condiciones a los refugiados tenemos
análisis desde madrid españa
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y el mundo aquí en las 24
bienvenidos de nuevo yo soy liliana
valencia iniciamos en perú donde se
agudiza la crisis política en torno al
juicio contra el presidente de martín
vizcarra por su supuesta incapacidad
moral permanente la acusación tiene
origen en la revelación de unos audios
entre el presidente y sus asesores donde
supuestamente les pedía mentir en una
investigación sobre un contrato
irregular del ministerio de cultura- a
un cantante
ahora el primer ministro walter martos
jefe del congreso manuel merino e
intento de complotar involucrar a las
fuerzas armadas en un pedido de
destitución del mandatario
matos apareció en una rueda de prensa
rodeado de altos mandos militares junto
a quienes denunció el accionar de merino
quien contactó a las fuerzas armadas
buscando respaldo y es que justamente
merino asumiría la presidencia si
vizcarra es destituido andrea rincón nos
cuenta más en este el reportaje
[Música]
cada vez que una filtración política ve
la luz en perú la cúpula del ejecutivo
tiembla y la historia ha demostrado que
incluso cae en mayo el diario peruano
gestión publicó una explosiva
investigación en la que el hasta
entonces desconocido cantante de ricardo
cisneros que presumía de su cercanía con
el mandatario suscribió nueve contratos
con el ministerio de cultura- entre 2018
año en que vizcarra ha asumido la
presidencia y 2020 por uno de ellos le
pagaron hasta ocho mil quinientos
dólares se trató de una conferencia
virtual que ofreció en plena pandemia
sin mostrar experiencia en el tema
recientemente se publicaron tres audios
en los que vizcarra estaría ajustando su
versión sobre los vínculos con el
artista el congreso controlado por
opositores fujimoristas vio una
oportunidad como todo favor dos entonces
cinco congresistas
en contra 36 abstención el 24
en consecuencia ha sido admitida la
moción de orden del día del pedido de
vacancia del presidente de república
esto abre las puertas para someter a
vizcarra a un juicio de destitución y el
gobierno reaccionó la actitud del
presidente del congreso ha sido
temeraria
al pretender involucrar a las fuerzas
armadas en un proceso político los
antecesores de vizcarra que estuvieron
en el centro de filtraciones no salieron
me librados los vladivideos una
filtración que reveló los sobornos que
recibían políticos en el gobierno de
fujimori en el 2000 terminaron con su
renuncia
en 2018 una grabación en la que el
congresista kenji fujimori negociaba con
sus padres para evitar un proceso de
vacancia sobre kuczynski a cambio de
indultar a su padre terminó en la salida
del presidente es que yo renuncie tendrá
vizcarra mejor suerte
en colombia se vivió por cuarto día
consecutivo manifestaciones en contra de
la brutalidad policial esta vez con
menor violencia que las dos primeras la
alcaldesa bogotá claudia lópez condenó
la violencia de la última semana en el
país y convocó a un cacerolazo una
velatón a un concierto virtual como acto
de reconciliación las protestas tras la
muerte del abogado javier ordóñez a
manos de la policía durante la madrugada
del pasado miércoles dejan al menos 13
personas muertas en las diferentes
ciudades del país
a finales de mayo la organización
panamericana de la salud confirmó que
américa latina y el caribe se habían
convertido en el epicentro mundial del
coi 19 al no contar con infraestructura
para investigación y producción los
países del continente deben acudir a
otros métodos para contribuir en la
producción de una posible vacuna y un
eventual acceso a ella y por mauro navas
los científicos de todo el mundo están
en una carrera por poner fin a la
pandemia mediante el desarrollo de una
vacuna y américa latina es el terreno
para las pruebas desde que rusia anunció
en agosto la primera inyección contra el
coronavirus varios países
latinoamericanos se mostraron
interesados en recibir las dosis el
presidente vladimir putin acordó el
envío de 32 millones de ellas a mexico y
se establecieron pactos para enviar
hasta 100 millones a varios países de la
región entre ellos venezuela y el estado
de paraná en brasil
una vez terminado el periodo
investigación
hasta el final del año podremos ofrecer
la vacuna rusa a todo españa pero brasil
tiene además otro acuerdo para producir
la vacuna desarrollada por la
universidad de oxford y astrazéneca en
sao paulo al igual que méxico y
argentina en donde se producirá esa
inyección para toda la región a precios
asequibles de entre 3 y 4 dólares por
dosis en cuanto a la vacuna que
desarrolla la estadounidense johnson y
johnson son 6 los países con voluntarios
en las fases de prueba brass
colombia méxico chile argentina y perú
en este último esta semana 20 personas
comenzaron a recibir las primeras dosis
de una vacuna desarrollada por el
laboratorio chino sinovac participar en
estos estudios para el perú va a
permitir que el perú pueda negociar con
los actores principales en el mundo de
esta de este esfuerzo que ha hecho todas
las instituciones en laboratorios para
obtener un plazo relativamente corto una
vacuna cuba por su parte ya inició la
primera fase de su propia vacuna
soberana mientras que la organización
mundial de la salud junto con el
gobierno de costa rica lanzó en mayo un
grupo de trabajo para desarrollar una
eventual inyección los muertos a causa
de los incendios que arrasan la costa
oeste de eeuu ya se acercan a los 30 una
cifra que podría aumentar debido a las
personas desaparecidas
ahora se evalúan los costos de las
mortales comprar acciones en california
washington y oregón en este último
estado cientos de miles de ciudadanos
por un evacuados
de ellos ya pudieron regresar pero solo
para encontrar que el lugar al que
llamaban hogar quedó reducido a cenizas
una vez que las llamas retrocede en el
silencio abrumador es lo más
sorprendente gran parte de la pequeña
ciudad de phoenix quedó reducida a
cenizas carbonizadas y para marian
tellers que es como si hubieran arrojado
una bomba sobre su casa
y este era mi camino de entrada
mi porsche lavadora y secadora nueva
no tenía idea de que no volvería a ver
mi piano o mi garage
normal
gran parte de oregón permanece envuelta
en una neblina tóxica de humo pero son
las ruinas las que más durarán en la
ciudad de lions están en todas partes
pero jeff que esto es un afortunado el
fuego se detuvo escasos metros de su
casa
neighbors auster down
por esta ley
la casa de un vecino se quemó pero el
departamento de bomberos tuvo mojar
todas las estructuras somos
increíblemente afortunados
y no solo son las viviendas lo que se
han perdido a pocos kilómetros de él
aaiún un niño de 12 años y su abuela
murieron quemados vivos en su coche
intentaban huir pero el fuego se movía
más rápido que ellos en total unas
500.000 personas en oregón se vieron
obligadas a abandonar sus hogares para
hacer frente a este éxodo funcionarios
locales establecieron campamentos aunque
no sólo los humanos necesitan
alojamiento tenemos un montón de llamas
cerdos y cabras
y tenemos más creo que alrededor de 180
apoyos allí más de 400 mil hectáreas de
tierra fueron arrasadas hasta ahora en
unos incendios que ya son considerados
los peores en la historia del estado de
oregon
hablamos ahora de la isla griega de
lesbos donde ya inició el traslado de
los refugiados de moria al nuevo
campamento tras el incendio que arrasó
con las carpas y los dejo a la
intemperie y sin pertenencias de las
casi 13.000 personas que se encontraban
en el campamento de migrantes más grande
del mundo unas doscientas ingresaron hoy
al nuevo espacio que tiene una capacidad
para apenas tres mil el proceso ha sido
lento ya que cada refugiado debe
someterse a la prueba del coi 19 antes
de poder ingresar a donde se le asigna
una carta el nuevo campamento se
encuentra a aproximadamente dos
kilómetros de mitilene la capital de
lesbos y tiene un área de alrededor de
12 hectáreas ahora la preocupación tiene
que ver con las 10.000 personas que no
van a poder ingresar al nuevo espacio y
que ahora se encuentran totalmente
desprotegidas
para analizar esta información nos
comunicamos con maría jesús vega
portavoz de acnur en españa que se
conecta con nosotros desde madrid
debería fra 24 y cuéntenos cómo veíamos
el nuevo espacio nuevo campamento tiene
justamente cada vida solo para 3.000
personas pero memoria vivían alrededor
de 13 mil qué va a pasar con los otros
10.000 refugiados en estas condiciones
así es las autoridades diga se están
poniendo en marcha este campamento desde
acnur
hemos puesto a disposición de el
gobierno de grecia 2000 carpas tiendas
de campaña que podrían alojar a la
totalidad de estas personas que se han
quedado solicitantes de asilo refugiados
que se han quedado en situación de calle
y que llevan ya varios días algunos de
ellos durmiendo a la intemperie en
playas en bosques y muchos de ellos
están en situación muy vulnerable
enfermos embarazadas niños muy pequeños
entonces este trabajo que están
desarrollando en las autoridades griegas
con apoyo de expertos en logística de
acnur y con los materiales que les
estamos ofreciendo pues es lo que
tratamos ahora mismo de que pueda
agilizarse para que haya más personas
que puedan tener un techo bajo el que
cobijarse después de esta última
experiencia tan tremenda que han tenido
que vivir
bueno pero más allá de esta nueva crisis
desatada tras el incendio y justamente
en la crisis migratoria en europa pues
es un problema estructural que hacer
para garantizar los derechos humanos de
los migrantes que viven en condiciones
de vulnerabilidad en campamentos como
éste el de moria que son los más grandes
del mundo
estamos hablando de una situación
endémica desde algunos hemos llamado la
atención desde hace muchísimos meses
sobre las terribles condiciones en las
que se encuentran a nivel global 27 mil
personas en este momento en las islas
del mar egeo en 5 centros gestionados
por el gobierno de grecia que tienen
capacidad para simplemente 5500 personas
entonces estas condiciones de
hacinamiento tremendas no solamente
están poniendo en riesgo de protección a
muchos de ellos de violaciones de
violencia sexual de abusos de robos de
conflictos sino que además con la
situación de kobe y de confinamiento no
hay posibilidad de poder guardar una
distancia social de poder hacer un
lavado de manos etcétera entonces esta
situación en la que estamos ahora
tratando de apoyar a las autoridades y
poniendo como digo a disposición todos
estos materiales desde tiendas bidones
letrina
tanques de agua que tanta falta hacen
tiene que ser una cosa absolutamente
provisional porque hacen falta
soluciones a largo plazo como venimos
reclamando desde hace muchísimo tiempo
necesitamos que se descongestionen las
islas griegas que la gente pueda tener
una dignidad en su forma de vida que
todos estos refugiados que vienen de
siria de irak de afganistán te de congo
de somalia después de haber vivido el
horror de guerras de persecución puedan
tener cierta habilidad cuando llegan a
europa
pues justamente es en la siguiente
pregunta porque el tema de la migración
no sólo le corresponde europa sino
también a los países de origen de los
migrantes qué responsabilidad tiene
europa en la crisis que se viven en
estos países por ejemplo que usted
menciona de medio oriente o de áfrica y
entonces qué hacer al respecto para
darle una solución estructural a este
tema
en primer lugar europa en este momento
lo que lo que debe hacer y ha habido hay
algunos pasos positivos es apoyar a
grecia tanto a nivel económico para
poder tener recursos para afrontar esta
situación de estas personas como a la
hora de reubicar y realojar a todos
estos refugiados que están entrando por
grecia porque es uno de los países
frontera del mediterráneo' como lo es
italia como lo es españa entonces hay
que hacer un reparto de
responsabilidades en todos los países la
unión europea
esto por un lado para que no continúe
esta situación en europa y por otro lado
lo que es fundamental es seguir
reforzando la inversión en procesos de
paz en identificación de situaciones de
riesgo en países antes de que los
conflictos estallen y también invertir
en resolución de conflictos y en
contribuciones internacionales en
cooperación internacional
si la gente pudiera tener
legislación y así los procedimientos de
asilo y una situación digna en los
países por los que transitan
probablemente no se marcharían nadie
sale por gusto y menos dejando su casa y
su país cuando hay un conflicto te vas
para salvar tu vida en a de tus hijos
así que en esa él se pone el foco
bueno pues agradecemos a maría jesús
vega portavoz de acnur en españa por
estar en prado 24 y también ustedes por
estar con nosotros continúen con más en
nuestra página web france24 puntos nos
vemos más adelante
[Música]